so we do this email thing called
unhelpful advise people callin for
problems and we try to answer okay
hopeful advice with Bobby
kalila and ghoulia Tom there he is hey
guys I'm gonna try and keep this short
and straight to the point my father had
an affair with another woman and left
our home to live with her my dad had a
vasectomy after I was born before
getting divorce and only being separated
with my mother for about eight months my
father had a vasectomy reversal and got
his GF pregnant now they are married my
mom rightfully feels bitter and
resentment towards my dad my dad wants
me to have a relationship with him and
his new wife and family and is that
about me not wanting to is it okay for
me not to want to and what should I try
or what should I do
I think hate and bitterness is the fuel
that keeps things moving in this world
you really believe that I know but my
father cheated on my mother constantly
and they finally got divorced and and I
remember the gum smacking [ __ ] that he
left my mother for it was difficult to
get close to that woman so I identify
explicitly with what this person is
saying it's a long hard road baby and
then you know my father through the
years he was with some some different
women of different qualities and then
later in life you know he the the the
woman he married from the Philippines I
love her she's great and then there was
you know a couple people before then
that were pretty great too so it's all
circumstantial and it sounds like
there's some hard cold bitter [ __ ] in
that email oh yeah I can relate you know
I just have we just deal with everything
in the opposite ways I think what would
you say no I'm just saying just in job
is watching you talk yeah and being so
clear about what you were saying why
what I experienced with that person I
understand I'm just saying there was no
vasectomies side of you I'm not fighting
with you but like I'm not fighting with
you I'm just telling you I'm just
telling you that you you just you know
I'm just observing you over the last
couple years at
, Club and whatever and I've always
thought this that do you just deal with
everything in a completely different way
than I do we internalize things
different we react differently our
thought processes are different it's
incredible
what God does right my thing is this cut
them cut them out the dad yeah forever
no it's right now for how long though
for me it's like look if that's how you
feel if that's how you feel then feel it
yeah yeah yeah true and if he's being an
inconsiderate [ __ ] right now and not
being you know not he's not I think
these things are so delicate if he it
sounds like he's being really indelicate
about the situation and every he's being
proud of the fact that he has his new
girlfriend is knocking her up and he he
doesn't have any regard for the feelings
of the family that he left behind but
he's not gonna be an [ __ ] forever so
maybe you can hate him right now feel
all those feelings but if he morphs into
a better man later on then you can have
a relationship with him but be open to
that but if you feel like [ __ ] right now
you're what that's warranted that's good
I think it sounds like he'd kind of
disrespected the mom and yeah it sounds
like there's hard feelings about that
and like my father you know he
disrespected my mom but you know like
you said he eventually became a better
guy yeah you know through you know after
he made many more mistakes you know but
I think ya feel your feelings your
obviously your mom still with us right
yes she's actually my mother turned 80
today Wow your dad passed my father was
killed by a drunk driver in 2009 oh my
gosh shoulda asked that Wow
we should have just gotten out of the
[ __ ] yep yeah really that happened
you know in 2009 mm-hmm oh my god was he
driving or was he just walking down he
had picked up his Philippine wife from
she was a caregiver picked her up from
work and was driving her home and was on
55 Highway and some drunk driver don't
like over 100 miles an hour was weaving
in and out of traffic
it is minivan from behind flipped three
or four times ended up in a ditch she
was badly hurt but not as bad as my
father and
who's in the hospital for like three
months then he got pneumonia everybody
oh my god we'll be right back
[Music]